l'activité avait pris fin en 1983 un des
fleurons de l'industrie française
enfin sous les pelleteuses le début d'un
an de travaux programmés pour rendre au
site
une apparence plus digne d'une des
portes d'entrée principale de la ville
un programme destiné à déconstruire une
grande partie des vieux bâtiments mais
qui prévoit surtout d'épargné quelques
vestiges symbolique de l'activité passée
l'objectif est au moins de garder la
mémoire industrielle de la ville de
besançon en gardant notamment un certain
nombre de bâtiments donc le bâtiment
historique du continuèrent de chardonnay
une partie de la cathédrale qu'on a
juste à côté de nous et puis de
construire donc sur le second semestre
de l'année 2019 un parc qui sera
accessible à l'ensemble des bisontins et
plus globalement ça sera un pôle qui
accueillera à la fois des loisirs du
sport de la culture sur les bords du
doubs et au pied de la citadelle de
besançon
le projet d'un parc faute de pouvoir
construire sur une zone inondable et qui
permettrait également à terme
d'accueillir les installations nautiques
du club d'aviron tout proche enfin rien
ne semble totalement arrêtée alors que
les entreprises de démolition doivent
d'abord procéder à une campagne
importante de désamiantage surtout si
c'est sécurisé et pérenniser l'ensemble
des vestiges mais surtout à aménager un
lieu pour permettre bisontin ou aux
touristes extérieurs de venir visiter ce
lieu emblématique et historique et si
possible donner envie ensuite de
réinvestir ces bâtiments
la fin d'un feuilleton d'aménagement
urbain qui devrait se conclure au début
de l'été 2010 9 avec un espace
d'activité historique rendue à ses
habitants